hey everybody how's it going my name is
mayuko and welcome back to my channel as
you can tell from the title of this
video it is time like finally time for
me to open up pandora's box and build my
very first ever mechanical keyboard i've
talked about keyboards multiple times
before on this channel things like desk
setups stream setups as well as a video
i made about the best keyboards for
programmers as well as my most recent
hhkb purchase but i have yet to actually
build one because i've always just
bought like the ones that are pre-built
and i have this amazing opportunity to
build one because the folks that keeps
for all sent me a keyboard kit i'm
scared to start this because yes it's
gonna just turn into an expensive hobby
because
it is it just is i know that like a lot
of y'all build keyboards and i have a
lot of friends who build mechanical
keyboards and i know it's an expensive
hobby but goodness i just wanna try it
out so this is gonna be kind of like a
build with me video going to show you
like my live reactions some parts are
probably going to be a little boring and
monotonous because it's going to be a
lot of like similar repetitive notions
but hey we're going to hang out and it's
going to be fun if you're into these
kinds of videos or just into my
personality and you enjoy watching this
one because i don't know maybe you're
gonna live vicariously through me or
something like that then make sure to
click subscribe also make sure to join
my membership program right here on
youtube by clicking the join button for
as low as 99 cents per month you get
access to a lot of different exclusive
perks as well as an exclusive video that
pairs along with this one i guess we
should build it
i'm gonna move this because heaven knows
that i am gonna spill it and we can't
have those kind of errors here today so
let me go get the parts
oh goodness
there's a lot of stuff okay i have
opened some of them but some of these i
haven't opened before so let's take a
look-see
all right inside box number one we've
got
oh pink keycaps oh
and black on white japanese keycaps oh
and stickers that's so nice we'll open
these in a little bit let's take a look
inside box number two
oh
desk mats oh these are hefty thank you
that's so nice let's take a look at
these keycaps real quick okay so before
i open everything and we get started
with building i just want to say a huge
thank you to keeps for all for sending
me all of this they're a really small
company and they're just starting to get
into the kind of mechanical keyboard
space and they sent me all this stuff
because they're really enthusiastic
about helping me build my very first
ever mechanical picky board so thank you
so much you can check them out in the
description box down below and you can
buy all of these things minus the cute
little desk mats as a whole entire
package uh pre-order starts from
september 20th to october 4th okay let's
look let's look at these pink ones first
oh
i like this ombre look at this
wow okay okay i'm into it i believe
there's two rows of key caps here so
there's this one
careful
and this one oh i like it i'm not a huge
pink fan to be honest but like this
ombre i can totally get with i love it
next i'm going to open the blue ones
because i have taken a look at these but
i just wanted to show you what they look
like
this is like one of my favorite colors
of navy blue so i think
i think this is what i'm going to put on
there we'll see what the black on white
also looks like too but it comes with
this
and then these keys i think these
actually come with more a lot of these
products are non-final a lot of them are
still prototypes so i would definitely
consult the website for the final
packaging and what's included but
this blue is gorgeous i like it a lot
okay
and then last but not least black on
white japanese keycaps
oh
that's clean
i think i think i'm gonna have to go
with these i like this white and this
black color
and the japanese keyboard part just
screams like it's me it's me and a
keyboard you know let's take a look at
what's underneath oh
these are so cute
i like that a lot it's very japanesey oh
they also sent me these keycaps they're
very cute they're izakaya themed and i
thought that was also a very me thing
because i love
izakaya
beer
related things i i like it too and then
here's the
build kit so it comes in a really nice
carrying case apparently this is not the
final color it's gonna match the actual
keycap colors but i've never had a
keyboard case before so i guess i can
travel with my keyboard now it's gonna
make me that super extra person at the
airport and the cafes and you know what
i'm okay with it so let's take a look
here we go
okay so the kit name is called the free
bird 60 full kit this is the case that
it comes with it's really hefty this is
an e coated aluminum case it comes in
black navy olive and white this is not
the final version again this is still a
prototype but goodness this this got
some weight on it and i really like that
the silicone goes all the way across
instead of like the tiny little rubber
feet and then let's look inside what's
here
so these are stabilizers
and then there's also some o-rings and
screws in there there's more o-rings and
screws in that one it comes with the
usb-c to usb cord
and then here's the pcb board and the
switch plate okay here's the switch
plate again this is not a final color
apparently there's gonna be one that's
gonna match this
um case color so it's gonna come in
white as well as black and aluminum
silicone dampener for the thawkiness
thank you love that
and then here's the pcb case
oh goodness i hope i don't like short
this or anything i am scared of using
electronics
because whenever i handle them scott who
majored in electrical engineering and
knows a lot more about this stuff is
like oh you go don't touch
that one part so i'm just gonna be
really careful with it
but you know it'll probably be fine
it'll probably be fine i think i'll be
okay
okay so here's the pcb board on the back
it says keebs for all which is great
so this pcb board is the fb60 hot
swappable pcb board so i don't have to
solder anything which literally that was
like one of the biggest
blockers really for me in wanting to
build a keyboard because
i suck at soldering i'm not gonna lie to
you i am terrible at soldering and it
terrifies me so the fact that i can
literally just push things in and it
works
my kind of mechanical keyboard gotta say
oh almost forgot gotta show the
different switches that they sent me so
these switches are gateron milky yellows
apparently they're very quiet and
they're very cute so i'm excited to try
them out i've only ever really typed on
cherry mx keys as well as the
whatever is inside the hhkb
what is it called what is it called
i want to say it starts with the th
this one this one is what i'm thinking
about so the folks at cubesforall sent
me all this they also sent me like a
lovely build guide which i did watch but
i'm not gonna lie to you i don't really
know what i'm doing
i'm very bad at electronics i'm just i
like things to be in a complete state
but you know what today is a day for
trying new things and seeking out new
possibilities and learning and probably
making a mistake or two but at the end
of it i'm hoping i'm promising myself
that there will be a keyboard that i
will add an audio test for at the very
end because that's like one of my
favorite things about keyboard videos
that i get to add this like audio test
at the end to show you how it sounds
using a really good microphone okay
let's
get building i don't remember what i'm
supposed to do first okay so here's what
i'm going to do first because this is
the easiest thing i'm going to put
this thing
on here because that's super intuitive
step one
is that right
i hope that's right
done
okay so what i believe i have to do next
is build the stabilizers which is not
part of the guide but you know what
let's just wing it from the get-go we're
just gonna try things out and we're
gonna see how it goes also note i'm not
gonna be lubing anything because yo girl
doesn't know how to do that and i feel
like that's the next level up and i'm
just trying to get a functional thing
here today you know what i mean okay i'm
looking at this and this makes no sense
so guess what we're gonna do we're gonna
check some youtube videos
it's starting to make sense to me though
i think i got it i think i got it oh
nope i don't remember how to do it oh
poo
[Music]
ah
did i get it i think i got it i i think
i'm proud of myself i'm not really sure
if it all comes together at the end
it'll be a freaking miracle but i've got
at least a model this is some small
small hands
important
last click here we go
okay
i think i did it so next this is very
similar to other things that i've done
in that it's um screwing
screws into a thing but wow is it much
much smaller than what i'm used to how
does that fit i don't get it i think
what i wasn't supposed to do is to screw
this in just yet let me take that out
big hole
i'm so afraid of breaking the pcb board
oh
i did it
i did it and then i
screw the oh my
look at what look at what's happened
stabilize the
stabilizers righty tighty lefty loosey
you know i feel like mechanical
keyboards are like the new
gundam kit sort of
i never made the gundam kits or anything
like that but i feel like it hits a
similar target demographic of people who
like
building tiny things
with their hands
except i guess keyboards are a little
bit more utilitarian because
most people create them to
use them and gundams
are usually there on display i don't
know i don't know what people do with
their gundam like if you like building
that kind of stuff you're probably gonna
like building keyboards not gonna lie
and then i think the other thing too is
mechanical keyboards are just like
so much more
accessible or like you don't have to
have watched the entire gundam anime in
order to appreciate it
you just have to kind of like typing
so far i don't know if i'll get into
mechanical keyboards maybe maybe i think
it's that like
by making something and then you realize
that like when you use it you're like
damn
i made this which is the cool part
because i do like making stuff i've made
that picture shelf right behind me i
also made the thing that this light bulb
is hanging up on but i made a lot of
stuff for my own room because i wanted
custom pieces well they didn't need to
be custom i just couldn't find what i
wanted on sale anywhere am i doing this
wrong
oh i'm doing this wrong all right
from the top
also i just want to say
i'm sorry if any of you are cringing to
any part of this um as you're watching
me build it i am such a beginner and i
just don't know what i'm doing so
please be nice to me in the comments
because
i don't know what i'm doing i welcome
constructive feedback but your girl is
trying her best okay
you know what i think
i truly believe that like in order to
learn something
really learn it you got to like make a
big mistake first well that's not
necessarily you can definitely learn
from others mistakes and you don't have
to learn from a mistake
in order to learn at all but for me i
find that just like being unafraid of
trying and just going for it is like
the best way to like try things out and
do it because i think there's something
about like you know what when you've
really failed
feeling that failure in your bones and
being like you know what
that sucked
i'm never gonna do it again
okay there we go
everybody's happy
no it's just not going in
oh
what's wrong with you
yo everyone makes this look so easy but
it's like really hard
i do think maybe this is the hardest
part
of building a keyboard though
okay
got it
wow am i gonna take these out at some
point and then properly lube the
switches
probably not okay
we're looking good
we're looking good we got one more i
wish i had like three hands to do this
i did
i freaking did it
so i believe what comes next i hope what
comes next
is installing the switches this part's
going to be very monotonous i believe
all right so next i'm going to install
the switches onto the switch plate is
that what this is called this is called
the switch plate and then i'm going to
install onto the pcb board because i've
been told that that's easier that way
so i hope this is going to be easier
than adding the
stabilizers so this one i'm going to
consult how the direction of this
because it's supposed to go downwards i
think i believe downwards is north
facing
and then upwards and south facing
this is already proving to be so much
easier than the stabilizers
so yay
the best part is that i know that if i
mess up i can use this thing to pull it
out oh so this kit also by the way is
called freebird 60 so it's technically a
60 keyboard but you can actually
configure it and install it to be 65 and
customize it to what you want because i
didn't say this in my hhqb video because
i forgot about it but the fact that it
doesn't have arrow keys is kind of
annoying i've actually like programmed
my hhkb to use the function and the wasd
keys as a replacement but i would much
rather have arrow keys so i'm excited to
have arrow keys back again okay i'm
going to try installing it onto the
plate now
oh
is that a connection
you can do it my yuko you are okay
bubble i think that's in
but hard to tell i hope i didn't break
any
oh my gosh the anxiety is real while you
build this there's probably like a way
to install these where you're like not
hurting any of the pins
and i just don't know how to do that
but they did tell me
as troubleshooting if
one of the
keys don't work is probably because one
of the little like
leg thingies are bent
and not that like there's actually wrong
connection
okay
i did it i have installed all the
switches
so
now i'm gonna install this onto here
don't oh my god i thought i almost lost
it again
you know i always thought i was someone
who could do like detailed work like
this
but after this i'm not so sure putting
the overall because o-ring is fat i mean
look at this thing it's fat
can you see it
okay
now i just gotta screw it on
i think that's it
now i think i just gotta put the key
caps on i'm gonna put on these ones the
only like cold already the only thing
i'm super particular about
in terms of keycaps is my friend taught
me about putting on the space bar
backwards so instead of
typing like this on the thumb
putting it like this
did i install you incorrectly
oh
oh dude the sound of this i can already
tell i'm gonna like this
and a plus
okay yo i think i'm done take a look wow
that thing is heavy
take a look at this custom built
mechanical keyboard
i'm pretty happy with how it turned out
yo i gotta say
this case
like makes this keyboard infinitely
better than any keyboards i've ever had
it's just so hefty like this is probably
like
five pounds three to five pounds it's
just so heavy
shall we test this thing i think it's
time to test it so
key tester my q doesn't work my six
doesn't work i just work
wow wow this is bad a lot of my keys
don't work
all right well let me show you the
results
here are all of the keys that work
i would say that's about a 50
rate of success
so i do think i gotta take it back out
again and then test things out but
hey thank you so much for watching i i
think i would call this to success
there's like obviously mistakes that
i've made
and you saw them you saw me make them
which is totally fine
but i would say that yo i would totally
use this on a day-to-day basis and i'm
excited to once i fix everything thank
you all so much for watching again all
the information about all the things
that i used are in the description box
down below thank you again so much to
cubes for all for sending me this kit
you'll find their link as well as my
affiliate link in the description box
again this kit the freebird 60 build kit
which includes the case the pcb the
plate as well as the switches in keycaps
is going to go on pre-order from
september 20th to october 4th if you
pre-order now then you'll get it around
january time-ish and so i hope you all
try it out overall in my mechanical
keyboard experience i would say this was
fun i think the whole like hot-swappable
switches make this so much more easier
and fun to do instead of soldering so i
think i would do this again but i know a
little bit more what to expect next time
and
i think i can do a better job so i am
excited to take this apart and put it
back together again because that's what
you're supposed to do with mechanical
keyboards when they don't work that's
really why people build their own
keyboards to begin with because they
want to customize each and every part of
the keyboard process everything from the
keycaps to the switches to the pcb board
underneath and the layout as well as the
case and how damp the sound is i will
add a sound test for you at the end of
this and so you can
hear how it sounds if you remember then
make sure to check out the exclusive
video for you in the description box
down below and if you're not a member
you can come join us and get access to
that and many more other perks for as
low as 99 cents a month all right
everybody thank you so much for being on
this journey with me thank you for
coming along to it i hope you enjoy
these keyword videos and who knows maybe
i will do more keyboard videos in the
future and if you'd like me to then make
sure to leave a comment down below i
hope that i didn't make anybody cringe
too hard and uh this is fun thanks for
hanging out and i'll see you next time
bye
[Music]
you